violet pote j'espère que vous allez bien
petite vidéo de la vallée de mauron go
en californie alors je venu pour filmer
des petites choses sympas mais là je
prends un petit peu de temps dans le
désert loin du bruit digitales des
réseaux sociaux
et franchement ça fait du bien mais j'ai
quand même vu le dernier épisode de game
of thrones et faucon en bas mais on va
en parler à l'intérieur parce que avec
le vent et c'est pas hyper pratique
tuez moi
évidemment va y avoir plein de spoil
donc si vous l'avez pas vu ne regardez
pas la vidéo la chaire hotline quand
même et rené plus tard l'air sous la vue
pouvait lâcher votre langue aussi en
fait le truc a game of thrones c'est que
tous les persos son trauma de bouffe et
plus on avance dans la série et pour se
rend compte du besoin de psychothérapie
et à quel point les choses peuvent être
graves
si on n'en bénéficient pas notamment un
personnage qui partiront cacahuètes
[Musique]
ouais daenerys elle est clairement en
souffrance déjà elle n'est orpheline
ensuite son frère c'est un bâtard quand
je dis pas tache pas de fils de roi
cacher ou quoi quand je parle de salles
ordures de merde la meuf se fait violé
et maltraité par aquaman après ça
devient maman de dragon ce qui est super
stylé et elle va enchaîner les succès
libéré les peuples tout ça tout ça en
gros elle se donne un destin incroyable
qui est celui d'une libératrice de
peuples en fait et donc et continue son
petit bonhomme de chemin
elle est grosse et là ça se passe pas ou
est déjà une personne y aura un le mec
qui a planté sa quête choix dans la
fanzone la soeur du mag quel kiff ne
l'acceptent pas trop le mec qui fait
d'ailleurs c'est son neveu elle lui
demande de le dire à personne
il s'emballe et steq en inde épisode
tattoo estero ski au courant leur baril
cela trahi bref sarah pas ouf
donc si je résume avec le coup du destin
exceptionnel on a une surestimation de
soi même un égocentrisme
ensuite on a une grande méfiance à une
forme de crainte et de rancoeur envers
les autres et enfin avec ce qui se passe
dans l'épisode où elle brûle une ville
on peut dire qu'il ya une fausseté du
jugement c'est à dire une logique basée
sur des notions sélectionnés et partial
on voit notamment avec cette scène
[Musique]
cet orgueil cette méfiance et cette
fausse du jugement
ces trois symptômes de la paranoïa c'est
à dire le trouble mental quel est son
père élise 2 targaryen dit hérisse le
dément mais aussi le roi croûte
parce que dans ses excès de colère sur
le trône de fer en fait il se blessait
du coup ils avaient des croûtes donc le
roi croûte on va rester sur hérisse le
dément puisse-t-il et il faut savoir
qu'il est un facteur génétique à la
paranoïa et en plus les targaryen c'est
pas les meilleurs pour amener de
nouveaux gènes dans leur patrimoine
donc ça augmente les risques il ya autre
chose d'important c'est qu'elle a non
seulement facteur stress j'aurai la
grosse bataille mais surtout elle perd
1,1
ces facteurs protecteurs genre soeur
jorat mais sans des l'amour de john bref
et du coup ça peut entraîner une
décompensation c'est-à-dire qu'elles
n'arrivent plus à compenser son trouble
avec ses forces et donc il pète les
plombs et s'assit nery sall avait un psy
elle l'aurait peut-être anticipé
elle se serait posée elle aurait parlé
de son passé et de cette rom accédera il
ou elle lui aurait dit que peut-être en
proie à un délire
allez lire que maurice did un or lot
français a décrit comme celui de
l'idéaliste passionné je vous lis
l'explication sur wikipédia le sujet est
passionné par une cause politique
mystique sociale il se donne mission de
la portée de la transmettre de manière
fanatique et d'en être le message est
infatigable
selon quentin debré un psychiatre
français l'idéal du paranoïaque et
rigide non révisable non discutable le
paranoïaque incorpore la réalité mais
dans un système imperméable à
l'expérience
il est privé de toute dialectique
intérieure ne se pose jamais de
questions il est incapable
d'autocritique ce peut être un
théoricien politique
un inventeur un prophète qui ont trouvé
leur solution aux grands problèmes de
l'humanité
et perso je trouve que ça répond bien
aux prix fhb de daenerys est donc un psy
aurait capté sa et aurait aidé daenerys
à souffrir le moins possible et si elle
était prête à passer à l'action et à
faire un truc grave genre par exemple
brûler une ville avec un dragon
eh ben elle aurait sûrement été
hospitalisés sans consentement
franchement la prochaine fois formé des
[ __ ] psy après si c'est pour des
raisons de budget on paie quelques
cascadeur et quelques effets spéciaux et
juste mettait des psys quoi soir et
franchement ça aurait pas mal aidé
l'assaillent bon après tout les
problèmes ne se règlent pas comme par
magie qu'on va voir un psy c'est pas
mécanique
ça peut aider au passage mauricie
d'insister pour dire que les jd liste
passionné né fait pas délirant et
finalement c'est une catégorie qui a
disparu dans les grandes classification
internationale autres ministres gain de
soustraire la scène où john par la
daenerys pour savoir à quel point les
enjeux
[Musique]
quand tu te vois quelqu'un aussi vite là
c'est quoi cette publication à deux
balles il aurait pu utiliser la
communication non violente au sb des
eaux pour observation sans jugement des
crises j'observe que tu as brûlé une
ville avec beaucoup de gens dedans
est-ce pour gentiment je dis ce que je
ressens je ressens de la peine mais
aussi de la peur b pour besoin j'exprime
mes besoins profonds j'ai besoin d'être
assurés de te faire confiance et de me
projeter avec toi comme rennes et des
pour demande mais pas exigences
pourrais-tu discuter avec moi de tes
décisions importantes et être clémente
dans ses conquêtes
voilà et après on regarde ce qu'elle dit
et si elle continue là on l'a but mais
au moins tu auras essayer en tout cas je
me suis connecté récemment aux réseaux
sociaux et j'ai été surpris de voir
qu'il y avait carrément une pétition qui
gens qui s'appellent reflète la saison 8
avec des auteurs compétents qu'elle ait
récolté genre 1,5 million de signatures
j'avoue j'ai du mal à comprendre c'est
comme si la série appartenaient au fan
art que non en fait c'est une oeuvre
artistique avec un point de vue une
intention des choses que ça se respecte
même si on n'aime pas c'est picasso il
fait une oeuvre que les gens n'aiment
pas ils n'ont pas lui demander de
changer la couleur par exemple
et puis même si la fin était pourri je
crois qu'au final ça change pas grand
chose
on juge pas une oeuvre juste à sapin
c'est aussi le voyage qui compte
lost par exemple ma scène préférée dont
la fin a été énormément critiqué et je
comprends tout à fait mais ça reste ma
série préférée est le truc assez fou ce
que j'écris ces lignes
j'étais dans un café est en fait à côté
de moi je me suis rendu compte qu'il y
avait un acteur de la série lost qui
joue juste mon personnage préféré john
locke voit la petite photo donc moment
exceptionnel beaucoup de chance voilà
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu si
vous aussi vous vous demandez si vous
devez aller voir un psy
ça vaut peut-être le coup d'y aller je
sais pas je remercie jeff dupes syllabes
qui a
relu cette vidéo et qui m'a permis de
donner quelques précisions donc n'hésite
pas à aller voir sa chaîne c'est
extrêmement intéressant
moi je vous revois très bientôt love
peace ciao